well we had Saved by the Bell the
college years now we have single white
female the college years the roommate we
have all had a creepy one so this
movie's a really simple concept hot girl
goes to college you get two really
creepy obsessive roommate now this girl
was obsessive crazy manipulative overly
dramatic so they should have called it
what it really was basic chick the movie
just saying now we've all seen this
story before and this movie offers
nothing new nothing new enjoyable
threatening that would have been nice
this movie's just really boring 98% of
it consists of this room a mean mugging
everybody
yeah basic movie poster glare that's it
but it's not threatening cuz I've seen
chicks give that look like a hundred
times over if I had a dime for every
time I saw a girl give that look I could
fix the recession like tonight and the
main chick she's hot she starts dating
this dude in the movie who's the that
guy of cocky movie guys him you know and
there's a scene where the creepy
roommates like stalking him in this
library and just given him the mean mug
without him scene of course cuz it makes
it threatening but it's just not
threatening to me because there's no way
that chicks gonna take on that dude from
that generic fighting movie that would
be like a little kitten taking on the
dude from the generic fighting movie get
Ledger's Joker John Lithgow from Dexter
season 4 then we're talking some crazy
[ __ ] tell then just a pissed-off chick
that if I saw mean-mugging me I'd just
go but this movie does one thing really
well that is proof Einstein's theory of
relativity I was watching this movie I
swore to God the end was like four
minutes away I was just like I've been
sitting here for two hours I've seen
everything build-up it's coming looked
at my watch one hour it seemed like two
which means the movie seems like for at
least three it seems a lot longer than
it is his time is truly relative
apparently shitty acting in a shitty
script in a generic movie makes time
slow down I don't know if Einstein
called that but he was around the
ballpark at that point though I almost
walked out no way I was gonna spend what
seems like four hours to me in a movie
that should have been titled who gives a
[ __ ] the movie but I haven't walked out
of a movie yet names starting now was
this movie [ __ ] yeah it was generic
dog [ __ ] on PMS I'm sorry guys you got
nothing in theaters right now this sucks
I don't know entertain yourself this
weekend like play baseball make a
YouTube video do homework
dry hump a cactus anything that's more
enjoyable than watching the roommate but
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more we're near in two hundred
videos that's awesome